hi my name is Amberly Gonzalez and I
play KVs in Star Wars Outlaws
caves is a thief she's a scoundrel she's
really good at sneaking around you know
she's charming and she'll like talk to
you but she's already taking all your
things she isn't perfect at it but she
always seems to get away with it
Kay really finds herself in a bit of a
jam you know she's got a bounty on her
back and is trying to find work that's
when she starts to really realize I kind
of like this underworld business I kind
of like this world and she's trying to
thrive on it she has to survive because
nobody else will save her unless it's
her the only person that she has is her
companion NYX they're not even human but
that is the closest thing she has to
feeling a part of something in the world
I also think that Nyx in a lot of ways
is kind of an extension of Kate both in
a gameplay sense or a story sense you
know and gameplay allows Kay to do
things she never thought possible and in
the story it's also a way for K to kind
of incense when something's off or or
see an opportunity or that kind of thing
really they're completely connected I
love that relationship I'm so excited
for people to meet next because they're
going to fall in love with him too
[Music]
Outlaws takes place right between The
Empire Strikes Back and Return of the
Jedi so it's the civil war between the
rebellion and the Empire that has
actually created this pocket of
opportunity for syndicates and criminal
organizations to rise up in that space
we've got the Pikes we've got the Huts
we've got a new Syndicate that we've
crafted for this game called the yeshiga
plan and one of the phrases we always
held on to was this notion of you live
and die by your reputation so it's
really exciting 4K and hopefully for
players she's so Fearless you'll see her
just go for it and there's no stopping
her even when there's danger involved
even when there's fear underneath it
she'll never let you see it not really
for a scoundrel story you know you
really have to ask yourself when is
enough enough how far is K willing to go
to land that big score and those are
questions she's going to tackle all
through the whole story
we worked with lucasfilm every step of
the way in crafting the story and they
were an invaluable partner in helping us
Create and Craft this thing they were
really embracing us with open arms in
terms of hey we wanted to focus on the
underworld we want to focus on an outlaw
navigating through that space But we're
sort of there to help guide and point
out like hey here's an opportunity you
might not have looked at or there's a
character you might might want to
consider so really it was a partnership
through and through
I feel like this is one of the biggest
if not the biggest franchise of our
lifetime the themes like everything has
just been a part of our world and for me
and and for the world of Star Wars I
know that people are going to love this
game not just for how amazing the
gameplay is but like the story itself to
see a young girl become a woman and
become an outlaw what are you worried no
humberly's energy her humor her wit all
of that really has kind of helped inform
the character she has a way of jumping
between that matinee action high-stakes
the tone to shifting to really intimate
really personal performances that make
you connect to Kate getting to bring my
own heart and then mix it in with that
confidence and her toughness and her
charm and wit it's it's really fun it
makes her very endearing even though
she's a very tough person
you won't make a doctor shower alive
Maybe
and yeah it kind of feels like she was
always meant to be okay she informs it
in every way
I love bringing a character like this to
life and it's an honor honestly to be a
part of this world it's definitely a
dream come true and I'm still doing it
so literally like about to hop and do a
scene right now so it's all just
exciting and I feel now I'm really
locked into the character the team is
amazing and I feel very supported and
I'm happy that they found me because I
feel like I was meant to play this role
make sure to catch me alongside with
some developers and cast members at
Comic-Con International this July in San
Diego
[Music]